on va avoir un stand sur chaque ville
étape nous seront présentes pour
répondre à toutes les questions des
martiniquais sur le recyclage des piles
comment ça fonctionne pourquoi se
recycler et puis aussi nous aurons à un
quizz de sensibilisation avec des lots à
gagner
alors le message à faire passer c'est de
changer ses habitudes
c'est de ne plus garder les piles au fin
fond d'un tiroir ne plus les jeter dans
une poubelle et surtout de les ramener
dans les bornes parce que 73 % des
composants des piles sont recyclables
on peut en faire des vélos on peut en
faire des clés on peut en faire des
canettes on peut en faire tellement de
choses et aujourd'hui c'est dommage de
malheureusement cette gâcher le
territoire martinique et alors qu'on
peut en faire quelque chose de mieux
nous espérons que ce sera un événement
effectivement qui fera que les
martiniquais se mobiliseront pour en
savoir plus sur la collecte des piles
usagées
et puis pour maintenant les apporter
encore plus dans les points de collecte
de scarlett batribox voulons rappeler le
danger
je suis depuis les points bas c'est
comme tout de tous pour tous qu'on jette
aujourd'hui dans la poubelle on essaye
de deux mois ont jeté dans la poubelle
parce que tout ce qui est dans la
poubelle ménagère fini soit lent
glissement soit à être brûlés et c'est
pas l'objectif aujourd'hui ce qu'on veut
c'est ne plus utiliser les ressources de
la planète
et puis justement à les valoriser